[Música]
hoy vamos a firmar un decreto supremo
que convoca a todos los chilenos y
chilenas a participar en un plebiscito
constitucional que vamos a realizar el
domingo 26 de abril del año que está a
punto de comenzar
ahora yo no creo profundamente que la
nueva constitución cambie todo porque no
lo va a hacer pero si es el primer paso
si es el primer paso y antes de este
primer paso que es la constitución no
qué género la política sino que generó
el ciudadano en la calle
yo creo que no es banal que los
estudiantes y han sido los que empezaron
la rebelión que se produce el 18 de
octubre
el 18 de octubre lo que hay es una
rebelión no es una protesta es una gran
rebelión
que adquieren formas inéditas en chile y
que va copiando la otros países de
américa latina
y por lo tanto es una decisión que es
correcta que va a permitir desarrollar
todos los procesos electorales de
acuerdo a un nuevo calendario calendario
que además va a permitir lo más
importante que la gente participe que la
gente se informe
porque la prueba no es solamente una
decisión política es también un
restablecer esta dignidad que todos y
todas queremos y en eso están el respeto
a los derechos humanos como base de
cualquier democracia y en esta nueva
constitución se tiene que ver reflejado
convención constitucional para que sea
también paritaria por todas por todos y
por todos
al cambiar la una nueva constitución
corremos demasiado peligro para caer
en algo como lo que le pasó a venezuela
si le pasa a venezuela porque no nos va
a pasar a nosotros
es algo maravilloso o sea el sentimiento
de alegría que hay por la posibilidad de
avanzar de conseguir un chile más justo
más democrático
nunca se ha hecho en chile una
constitución con la participación
ciudadana nunca se ha hecho en el mundo
una constitución paritaria yo creo que
lo que vamos a hacer ahora en chile va a
merecer la atención de muchas partes del
mundo porque creo que no solo estamos
solucionando un problema nacional sino
que sí es cierto lo que te planteo desde
el comienzo estamos encontrando el
camino también a una cosa a una crisis
cultural en la que estamos inmersos todo
en el mundo
[Música]